okay so everyone wants to come for my
toes by the way I've cued us feet Kylie
Jenner is clapping back at the haters
who talked mad smack about her feet yeah
here's what went down the 22 year old
beauty mogul recently shared sexy bikini
pics of her and her sister Kendall on
Instagram but turns out some fans were
less focused on the gorgeousness that is
the Jenner sisters and more focused on
their feet you
that's when Kylie hit up her insta story
to call out the trolls for making fun of
her toes specifically that middle toe on
her right foot that appears to be
shorter than the rest of them okay so
everyone wants to come from the toes by
the way I've cued us feet and I broke
this middle toe in middle school and you
can't really there's nothing to do for a
broken toe so I just have to let it heal
how it wanted to heal
Kylie tried to show that when she flexes
her toes the middle one doesn't always
follow suit this is a weird-ass video
honestly she just took the words right
out of my mouth you could see it better
when I'm standing so when I flex this up
they're all normal and like in plays the
middle toe focus on the middle toe and
then when I flex this up this little guy
just like is out of place but here's my
favorite part
Kylie flip the switch and through her
sister under the bus
sharing a close-up pic of Kendall's feet
and writing I'm sorry but what no but
seriously
what I don't know I don't even like to
think about that then Kylie showed off
her feet by the pool as she hung out
with her two-year-old daughter stormy
family's money for cleaning
Factory thank God for stormy swooping in
to turn this story around with her
cuteness was it cold or warm this one
but according to Kylie's momager Kris
Jenner stormy might just get a little
brother or sister sometime soon my next
grandchild will come from Courtney
alright buddy Kylie Kris recently
stopped by The Ellen DeGeneres Show and
said she thinks Kylie could be the
daughter to give her another grandchild
next despite the fact that she and
Stormies dad travis scott are not
currently together even if they're back
together they're just great to
guarantors well there you have it folks
Stormy's cute kylie and travis aren't
together and kylie well she has cute ass
feet by the way i'm cute us feet EG
we'll be here to bring you all the
latest on Kylie so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens and I'll see you soon
[Music]